les fictions sont des forces matérielles
l'amour crée les mariages créer les
naissances et les crimes passionnels la
religion crée des communions créer des
conversions créer des guerres saintes
l'argent crée les achats créer
l'endettement créer les entreprises les
droits de l'homme créent des libertés
créer des lois et des interventions
militaires le propre des fiction c'est
qu'il s'agit d'entités non réelles au
sens où elles ne sont pas des réalités
objectives mais elles produisent des
effets réels et c'est ce qui fait dire à
Harari que l'ordre imaginaire est
incorporé dans l'ordre matériel
l'euro et le dollar sont des fictions
mais si votre patron ne vous donne pas
votre chèque à la fin du mois vous ne
pouvez plus manger
les fictions prennent part à la réalité
objective